foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Hogwarts platform nine and
three quarters and muggle bones
specifically we're going to be taking a
look at how a muggleborn student of
Hogwarts that is one with two muggle
parents would know how to navigate
King's cross station and get on to
platform nine and three quarters with a
platform that's invisible and a rail
line that heads to a magical School in
the Scottish Highlands I think it's safe
to say that getting to Hogwarts is a bit
of an unusual experience particularly if
you're embarking on such a journey for
the first time the platform can be
accessed by walking straight through the
barrier between platforms 9 and 10. but
this can be confusing if you're a a
muggle or B it's your first time in the
Harry Potter story Harry successfully
makes it onto the platform because of
the Weasleys who he luckily just so
happens to meet before he runs into them
he's completely lost well there you are
boy Platform 9 platform 10 your platform
should be somewhere in the middle but
they don't seem to have built it yet do
they he was quite right of course there
was a big plastic number nine of a one
platform and a big plastic number 10 of
the one next to it and in the middle
nothing at all what on Earth was he
going to do he was starting to attract a
lot of funny looks because of Hedwig
he'd have to ask someone he stopped a
passing guard but didn't dare mention
platform nine and three quarters the
guard had never heard of Hogwarts and
when Harry couldn't even tell him what
part of the country it was in he started
to get annoyed as though Harry was being
stupid on purpose getting desperate
Harry asked for the train that left at
11 o'clock but the guard said there
wasn't one in the end the guards throwed
away muttering about time wasters Harry
was now trying hard not to panic
according to the large clock of the
arrivals board he had 10 minutes love to
get on the train to Hogwarts and he had
no idea how to do it he was stranded in
the middle of a station with a trunk he
could hardly lift a pocket full of
wizard money and a large owl at this
point Harry is completely lost and
starts considering using his wand to
somehow open up the entrance but
fortunately for Harry at that moment a
group of people passed just behind him
and he caught a few words of what they
were saying Harry swung round the
speaker was a plump woman who was
talking to four boys all with flaming
red hair each of them was pushing a
trunk like Harry's in front of him and
they had an owl heart hammering Harry
pushed his cart after them they stopped
and so did he just near enough to hear
what they were saying now what's the
platform number said the boy's mother
excuse me Harry said to the plump woman
hello dear she said first time at
Hogwarts Ron's new too yes said Harry
the thing is the thing is I don't know
how to how to get onto the platform she
said kindly and Harry nodded not to
worry she said all you have to do is
walk straight at the barrier between
platforms 9 and 10. don't stop and don't
be scared you'll crash into it that's
very important best do it at a bit of a
run if you're nervous go on go now
before Ron uh okay said Harry but what
about Hermione and her parents what
about Justin Finch Flatley and Ken real
Muggles that is Muggles that aren't
magical even walk through the barrier I
don't recall saying anything about that
in the Hogwarts acceptance letter was
this something that Hagrid had just
forgotten or was this process just meant
to be exceedingly difficult for students
in Harry's situation traditionally the
Hogwarts acceptance letter informs new
students of their acceptance to Hong
Kong School of Witchcraft and Wizardry
and along with the latter includes a
list of required textbooks materials
required for the upcoming school year
when a witch or wizard from a magical
family receives this letter things are
fairly straightforward they know the
procedure and when the time comes for
them to go to school they're brought to
platform nine and three quarters and
sent off the procedure for mugglebones
however is a little bit different as I'm
sure you can imagine the shock and
surprise The Surge of confusion when
receiving a letter like that Hermione
said the following nobody in my family's
magic at all it was ever such a surprise
when I got my letter but I was ever so
pleased of course I mean it's the very
best School of Witchcraft there is Colin
creevy also weighed in on the process
it's amazing here isn't it I never knew
all the odd stuff I could do as magic
till I got the letter from Hogwarts my
dad's a Milkman he couldn't believe it
either so I'm taking a load of pictures
to send home to him in the case of
muggleborns Hogwarts dispatch is a
member of staff to travel to the home of
said mugglebone student so that the
letter can be properly introduced and
explained the books don't actually
acknowledge which staff member is
directly responsible for this however as
McGonagall is in charge of the registrar
it makes most sense that it would be her
responsibility I can't even begin to
imagine how difficult it would be to
explain magic to a muggle a real monster
of a task however if it's going to be
anyone I think that either Dumbledore or
McGonagall would be most convincing in
the films we see Dumbledore traveling to
wolves orphanage to inform Tom Riddle of
his acceptance to the school though he
was magical he had no parents that he
knew of so it was necessary for a member
of staff to come and explain the process
as well as the magical world presumably
part of this info session pertaining to
the World of Magic and the Magical
platform you need to access to reach
said school would be discussed along
with everything else however Harry had
different circumstances than most his
situation was more complicated in
Harry's case it was Hagrid that was
dispatched to inform Harry of Hogwarts
and the Magical World and that's because
the dazzies ever cruel refused to
entertain the idea of Harry attending
the school this meant that drastic
action had to be taken and Hagrid was
subsequently dispatched and while Hagrid
did a great job of introducing Harry to
Magic in some aspects in others he
certainly fell short namely Hagrid's
biggest error was forgetting to tell
Harry how to access the platform what
this means is that the process for
Muggles accessing platform nine and
three quarters isn't flawed Hagrid just
forgot to explain things to Harry in his
unique case I'd also like to point out
that Muggles can also access the
platform this is proven by the fact that
on the 1st of September 1971 Mr and Mrs
Evans took their witch daughter Lily
Evans Harry's mother to platform nine
and three quarters along with her muggle
sister petunia after dropping off their
kids the parents of muggle-born children
simply head back the way that they came
from walking back through the wall
between platforms 9 and 10. it's also
worth mentioning that there was a guard
stationed just outside the ticket
barrier Mona monitoring those that were
returning from platform nine and three
quarters it took quite a while for them
all to get off the platform a wise and
Old Guard was up by the ticket barrier
letting them go through the gate in twos
and threes so they didn't attract
attention by all bursting out of a solid
wall at once and alarming the Muggles
and that's it for this video I hope this
effectively answered the question of how
mugglebones get to platform nine and
three-quarters if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live